[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
et mokhtar si le birdie le vice-premier
ministre du kazakhstan ministre des
affaires étrangères est avec nous depuis
bruxelles merci d'être avec nous
merci à vous
le pays a été secoué par des violences
au début du mois de janvier des
manifestations pacifiques contre
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie se
sont transformées en émeutes violentes
les autorités ont accusé des terroristes
étrangers d'être à l'origine de ces
violences et ordonné une répression et
les autorités ont reçu un appui
militaire de la russie et des anciens
pays soviétiques
après plusieurs jours d'informations
contradictoires le procureur en chef a
dressé un bilan officiel 225 morts
cependant des groupes de défense des
droits humains des témoignages sur le
terrain font état d'un bilan beaucoup
plus lourd alors j'ai une question
simple ferez vous preuve de transparence
totale vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale concernant ce qui s'est
passé dans votre pays il ya quelques
jours
et à sang chaud absolument comme vous le
savez notre président a demandé à toutes
les agences de maintien de l'ordre de
créer un groupe d'investigation qui
lancera une enquête à grande échelle
des fenêtres les
la réception de tous les éléments de
preuve témoignant de l'implication de
groupes terroristes dans les attaques
contre les civils
les responsables gouvernementaux et les
forces de police nous les partagerons
avec eux nos partenaires et avec la
communauté internationale
nous sommes tout à fait prêts à coopérer
avec les ong internationales et avec les
groupes de défense des droits de l'homme
des nations unies et de l'eau
et donc qu'est-ce qu'ils auront accès
prince a monté un éventuel témoignage ou
est ce que vous leur fournir est
tout à fait une fois que nous aurons
reçu toutes les conclusions de l'enquêté
nous les partagerons et comme vous le
savez je suis à à bruxelles je suis venu
en europe pour rencontrer nos
partenaires à bruxelles demain à vienne
puis à genève
le but de ma visite est de partager des
informations de première main
tous disent casse
de discuter avec mes collègues afin de
voir comment nous pouvons coopérer
dana
rendre publiques les conclusions de
l'enquêté
le président kassim je m'attaque à eve a
parlé très tôt et je le cite de vingt
mille terroristes étrangers respectent
pas nos fds mais cela pose question car
aucune preuve n'a été produite
concernant ce chiffre énorme vingt mille
terroristes étrangers cela semble être
exagéré n'est ce pas
les vingt mille terroristes ne sont que
ceux d'al m'attire
mais ils sont encore plus nombreux si
l'on compte ceux des 11 autres régions
qui ont fait l'objet d' attaques
simultanément faut chaud
une chose est sûre comme je l' ai déjà
dit nous allons partager les conclusions
de l'enquêté qui seront accompagnés des
preuves que ces personnes appartiennent
à des groupes terroristes
vous maintenez le fait qu'il s'agissait
de terroristes étrangers on m'a parlé de
terroristes islamistes mais selon tous
les témoins sur le terrain ce n'était
pas le cas en réalité ce n'était pas des
terroristes étrangers des émeutiers
peut-être mais il semble que ce soit un
moyen pour le kazakhstan d'obtenir un
appui au niveau international
si
nos concitoyens ont partagé des éléments
de preuve et parmi ces militants armés
il y avait des personnes qui ne parlait
pas cazacu mêmes russes mais différentes
langues asiatiques
certains y ont parlé kazakh avec un fort
accent
l'équipe ce qui montre que ce n'était
pas des natifs du kazakhstan mais des
personnes qui avaient appris la langue
plus tard voilà les éléments qui
prouvent qu'il y avait bien des
étrangers parmi les terroristes
l'ancien président noursoultan
nazarbaïev il n'a pas été aperçu en
publié depuis le 28 décembre
il ya de nombreuses rumeurs qui
affirment qu'il aurait quitté le pays
qu'il serait peut-être mort ou en prison
où est il
alors pour être tout à fait honnête
personnellement je ne sais pas où il se
trouve en ce moment mais son directeur
de communication a déclaré qu'ils se
trouvaient au kazakhstan faut chaud
je sais qu'il n'est pas mort ou qui n'a
pas été arrêté
d'accord cependant on a vu au cours des
derniers jours que tout d'abord le
président tokayev l'avait démis de ses
fonctions le 5 janvier entre que chef du
conseil de sécurité du kazakhstan et
depuis le président a démis de leurs
fonctions des alliés très proches de
monsieur nazaire bf y compris des
membres de sa famille qui occupait des
postes clés à la tête des services
secrets et d'entreprises énergétiques
majeurs ge il semble qu'il y ait une
purge en cours ciblant les alliés les
plus proches de l'ancien président par
le nouveau régime peut-être parce qu'on
le soupçonne d'avoir joué un rôle dans
ce qui vient de se passer au kazakhstan
quelle est votre réponse
il soit à monter ses dettes et bien ce
que je peux dire
qu'avec l'arrivée de notre président
tokayev au poste de président du conseil
de sécurité du kazakhstan il y a eu une
période de transition
complique les dalles solde est comme
vous le savez
le transfert du pouvoir à a pris du
temps
le président tokayev est devenu chef du
parti au pouvoir constitutionnel ainsi
qu il ya eu des institutions
constitutionnelles comme l'assemblée
populaire du kazakhstan et enfin il a
pris ses fonctions en tant que président
du conseil de sécurité ce qui nourrit
quelques ensembles hier soir oui by day
oui mais le fait que certains de ses
gendres qui occupaient des positions de
pouvoir et d'été leur fonction est ce
que c'est parce que le président actuel
pense que son prédécesseur aurait pu
jouer un rôle dans les violences dont
nous avons été témoins
on est
[Musique]
comme vous le savez
l'ancien chef du conseil national de
sécurité
monsieur massimov a été arrêté
d'autres membres de ce conseil de
sécurité nationale
toutefois je suis convaincu que nous
devons attendre que l'enquêté soit menée
que le procès ait lieu et qu'un verdict
soit rendu avant de pouvoir dire s'il
était impliqué ou non dans ces émeutes
violentes d'accord mais vous ne l'écarté
pas et le fait que certains gendre du
président qui occupaient des positions
de pouvoir sur le plan économique le
fait qu'il soit évincé est le signe que
le président pense qu'il est un problème
dans la manière dont le pays a été géré
et qu'il est possible que monsieur
nazaire bf sa famille son cercle proche
et jouer à un rôle pour tenter de le
déstabiliser
saw vi yumin de vous parler de son
gendre monsieur kulibayev oui d'autres
alors comme vous le savez monsieur
kulibayev n'occuper aucun poste officiel
il était directeur de la chambre
nationale des entrepreneurs du
kazakhstan
latham et ken
il a décidé lui même de quitter ce poste
hier selon mes informations d'accord
mais ce n'est pas un hasard vous êtes
d'accord sur le fait qu'il a une
tentative du président peut-être
d'évincer certains
responsables parce que certaines
personnes ne les apprécie pas
je ne pense pas qu'il ait été poussé par
qui que ce soit
mais ce que je dirais c'est que notre
président lors de son dernier discours
au parlement a envoyé un message clair
aux habitants du kazakhstan nous devons
éviter d'avoir une répartition
disproportionnée des richesses et un
trop grand écart de salaire entre les
différents segments de la population
d'accord d'un art question car nous
n'avons plus de temps alors pour la
première fois il ya des appels
à une organisation dominée par la russie
on a appelé cette organisation
intervenir sur le plan militaire alors
l'effort semble quitté le kazakhstan
mais est ce que le kazakhstan est sous
l'influencé du président de la russie
vladimir poutine
et qu'est ce que cela veut dire quant à
sa capacité à mener une politique
étrangère indépendante
toutes ses dettes pour être honnête je
dois dire que nos agences de maintien de
l'ordre n'était pas prête pas prête à
repousser cette attaque terroriste à
grande échelle voilà pourquoi notre
président a décidé d'avoir recours à une
aide internationale to fight day bat lui
rêve pas mais
si on les lit galbées ce tour mais dans
le cas de l'hôtesse est la seule base
juridique pour avoir des forces
étrangères de maintien de la paix au
kazakhstan nous n'avons aucune autre
organisation ou conventions bilatérales
pour accueillir des forces étrangères
dans le pays voilà pourquoi nous avons
eu recours à l'eau tsc
sollicités puisqu'ils peuvent nous avons
reçu des forces des cinq états membres
l'arménie la biélorussie le kirghizstan
la russie et le tadjikistan
comme vous savez le mandat de ses forces
de maintien de la paix était très
strictement limitée à assurer la
sécurité des infrastructures
stratégiques
nous a permis de mobiliser le personnel
des agences de maintien de la paix et
les forces armées pour lutter contre ces
terroristes
complète comme vous le savez ils ont
terminé leur mission et sont en train de
quitter le kazakhstan depuis le 13
janvier rtx le retrait pendant environ
dix jours le temps de transférer
graduellement les responsabilités aux
agences du kazakhstan ce
quasar regency
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
moctar et le beurre dit il d'avoir été
dans l'ombre se tient sur france 24 des
merci de nous avoir suivis restez avec
nous vos plus d'informations
[Musique]